Let's see who else is on the phone at 6 1
7 8 3 0 47 50.
Let's try a caller.
This is crazy.
Now we're going to country code ninety two.
I have no idea what this is, but let's go
to country code ninety two.
Is this me?
Yes, it is.
Who's this where you calling from?
Well, I did.
My name was mine.
I'm calling from Pakistan.
How are you?
And please just take the phone a little further
from your mouth.
So you've come through a little more clearly.
Is it enough?
Yes.
Thank you.
OK.
I just wanted to say I'm a very big fan of
you.
I've been watching you since I was 14 years
old.
Amazing.
No.
Yeah.
So I really like you.
I saw you.
You were like the first progressive you would
do.
Very rich.
I started to watch you guys.
DOMANSKI.
This is incredible.
Let me ask you, my friend are in in Pakistan.
Are American progressive YouTubers known at
all like are you able to go to someone in
your community and say, hey, did you see that
Kyle Kolinsky clip?
And like someone else would say, oh, yeah,
I did see that.
Like, are these are these channels at all
followed in your country?
No, not TV.
They're not.
You're the only one I ask.
I actually I actually don't talk about politics
much with my friends.
OK.
So all all don't like dogs up against a progressive.
He used to be a source.
It is doing as well.
And it is.
So I talk about politics with them.
Love it.
I would love to hear you.
You're gonna need to pull the phone much further
from your mouth because you're coming through
so distorted.
But I would love to get a question from you
if you're able to just.
Just keep pulling that phone away from your
mouth.
OK.
Is it better?
No.
Yes, it is.
OK.
I just wanted to ask you how how would you
respond to the teams that the age limit is
slavey?
So you are associated down with dog?
Yes.
I normally socialists see that village vs
labor is some form of exploitation off of
it.
So how would you respond to that?
Well, already you've sort of you've gone from
saying wage labor is slavery to wage, labor
is exploitation.
Now, those are two very different scenarios.
I completely reject the idea that wage labor
on principle is slavery.
However, there is no doubt that there is some
degree.
If if we define exploitation as someone who
establishes the factory is profiting from
the labor of someone else, then that is a
form of exploitation.
Now, we might say that if the working conditions
are good, if everybody has good benefits and
is paid a fair wage, that that surplus that
the capitalist to use Marxist language earns
from the wage laborer, that it is a fair exchange
for taking the risk of establishing the factory
and buying the capital and the machines and
establishing human right, you know, all of
this different stuff, human resources, etc..
So slavery, I would say absolute that's that's
not, you know.
Of course, we can find situations where there
is slavery, indentured servitude, and I'm
against those the idea of exploitation.
We're now talking about, OK, what is a fair
amount of profit for the capitalist in exchange
for creating the factory, risking their capital,
employing other people, et cetera?
And then you're already talking about a gray
area.
If that makes sense in that that area is where
social democracy essentially operates.
What is a fair amount of profit for the capitalists?
And what should they be required to provide
in exchange to ensure that people have a living
wage and a social safety net?
David?
Yes.
Can I ask you just one final question?
My pleasure.
And I'm in America.
Are there any progressive governors that that
you admire that share our ideas as progressives?
There's no one that shares all of the ideas.
But you know what?
So Jay Inslee is really good on climate.
And, you know, you can sort of pick and choose
from different governors what what you like.
Listen, I so appreciate your call from Pakistan.
Tell me again what your name was.
My name's a smile, a smile.
Okay, very good.
I really appreciate your call.
I hope to hear from you again.
Oh, sure, sure.
I love this.
Bye bye.
Oh, great, Dave.
And as people can tell, you've gotta keep
the phone when people get right up on the
phone like that.
The phone system just cannot handle it.
So keep the.
I'll turn you up on my end.
Keep that phone away from your mouth.